in the audience so feel free to ask him
the hard questions
um okay so our motivation uh you know
come from you know General statistical
learning so this talk is mainly about
machine learning it's plus
um that it uses some ideas from from
this community
so our motivation really came from
looking at um statistical learning and
you know observing that most of the
performance guarantees that we are
concerned with and machine learning is
kind of this aggregate performance
guarantees average over a population
um and really most of the time we don't
try to say anything about any particular
in any performance guarantee for a
particular instance
um let alone what happens in the
subgroups or subpopulation so this is
kind of a cartoon that shows uh you know
how you know this this linear classifier
might be giving pretty good
classifications on average over a
population by some sub populations you
know like this one
um you know you're completely
misclassifying on half of their
the points there
um okay and then uh you know this you
know this kind of is important in the
context of trustworthy Ai and machine
learning where a lot of the failures the
standard machine learning and AI methods
um are really highlighted that the
individual or subgroup level and just
basically somehow it's misaligned with
the standard uh objective that we think
about in machine learning
okay so this is about uh this kind of
refining the
um the standard objectives in machine
learning which really uh came from a
really wonderful paper by uh by Rockland
and and Yona from
2021 and it's kind of a
um like an extension of this like a
there's a related kind of online
variance of this thing from from plum in
the course in 2020 and I'll see a little
bit more about these two um these two
Works in a bit because our work really
Builds on these two papers
um and they're largely motivated by uh
at least issues and fairness and machine
learning and AI
um they are really concerned about
um you know not just the classification
objectives or loss minimization
objectives but other kinds of objectives
they may care about like calibration
um but but you know from us coming from
just a standard machine learning uh um
background we're only just focus on loss
minimization and just make it even
simpler today look at binary
classification
actually our motivation came from this
other
um kind of line of work in machine
learning looking at robustness issues um
and another paper um fired us this paper
on hidden stratification
and they make this observation that you
know when you are using machine learning
to to trade models for for prediction
and applications usually the training
data you know not at all should be
should rarely be thought of as a like an
actual sample from the distribution you
care about it's mainly just a
distribution like a data set of
convenience you just get as much data as
you can
um who knows if this is representative
of the population you care about
and oftentimes you know this data is
actually kind of this population from
which you got the data stratified in
certain ways and what matters in the
downstream application is really maybe
just one stratum from this uh stratified
collection and so we would like to
formalize machine learning objectives
and ways of use using machine learning
so that um you know even we don't know
what the uh the downstream strata the
population that ultimately matters for
the application very different from the
entire population from if you've got
your data that somehow you know you can
develop machine use machine learning
methods that provide some guarantee for
the strata that matters
so
kind of at a high level uh what um
are we what we do is we look at this
multi-group generalization that's
standard uh statistical learning and
um yeah there's a lot of things that are
very similar to you know the classical
theory for physical learning
um and our main kind of contribution to
show how many like the standard sample
complexity guarantees in the classical
setup really can be ported over to this
kind of new multi-group setup
um so somehow the statistical aspects
are not that different but there are new
um kind of algorithmic techniques or
principles that we have to develop and
you know as like a example in the
classical setup
um they only commonly think that just
doing empirical risk minimization over a
large population or sample from your
population in multi-group setup this
that doesn't even necessarily make sense
anymore it made me predictors that are
you know much more complicated
okay so I'm going to try to get through
uh and describe to use you know in what
ways the the multi-group setup differ
from the standard um classical
statistical learning setup okay so here
there's kind of cast of characters for
the
um
uh for this problem
in the uh in the first two large kind
Spanish standard in the in the classical
setup that we're going to be thinking of
a data being drawn IED from some broad
population we call it t and just for
binary classification problems we have
those feature space and the label space
would just be zero one
and we're only going to be thinking
about finding classifier that are good
relative to some reference class or like
hypothesis or concept class or
hypothesis class we'll call it the
reference class H and we would like to
have you know find a classifier that
does as well as the best classifier from
these reference classes
and then the multi-group setup
introduces the family of subsets which
we call groups we call G these are just
again you can think of it either subset
of X or indicators for free groups
um eventually we will require these two
um
sets H and G to have finite AC dimension
don't worry about this
so um just kind of as a
um reminders that we're all on the same
page the way that the kind of standard
and statistical learning or agnostic
learning
um uh goals phrases in you know without
any groups involved is to
um if you're given some Target excess
error Epsilon we would like to take some
sample you know maybe growth with how
accurate you want things to be and maybe
how complex of a preference class you
would like to compete against get the
Mars sample of data from your population
and then eventually output a classifier
that's accurate and we want error rate
not too much larger than the best error
rate achievable within this reference
class
so this is uh just a standard
statistical learning or agnostic
learning setup that we're probably
familiar with and
well-known that suffices if you can
compute it to just let empty the
empirical risk minimizer within this
class stage and that will do this with
you know a very nice uh sample
complexity down
okay any questions about this uh so far
okay it should be uh very familiar um so
the multi-group set up in the paper by
uh by guy and now they they added this
twist where you now think about also um
not just caring about the error rate
with respect to the broad population but
also conditional on the inputs falling
Within These various groups
so what you like it's one classifier app
let's say which high probability for
every group that has sufficient
probability mass that your conditional
error rate a rate like this the error
rate of your classifier app give NG
which means that X condition on X volume
and G to be not much larger than the
best error rate you can get within this
reference plus specific to that group
specific to that group Gene and not much
larger means you know plus what you're
allowed to have excess Air at most
Epsilon
and you know one like basic observation
is that it's possible that none of the
hypotheses and the reference class can
achieve this guarantee because uh you
know what might be optimal for one group
um I completely disagree with what to do
for for a different group
okay so but if you can achieve this uh
guarantee this multi-group agnostic
guarantee is kind of a very nice uh
um even for this standard loss
minimization uh setup it has a lot of
nice applications and one of them is
just a hidden Tree application
application that I mentioned before
like if you have some data set you
collect your training data from a large
population but ultimately what matters
and for your downtrend application it's
a particular sub subpopulation
um if you can ensure that you get
satisfied this multi-group diagnostic
learning guarantee
um then for every uh potentially uh
meaningful down Downstream subgroup or
subpopulation or stratum that's kind of
well approximated by groups in your
family G
um we would be able to also say that you
you know satisfy this kind of learning
goal with respect to that that the
stratum s and you know this is you know
this requires like some notion of
multiplicative approximation of the the
sitting stratum s with respect to your
family of Group G
um so this kind of motivates us to
develop the algorithms that can achieve
some kind of multi-group guarantee with
respect to very broad families of groups
okay so so you know again this is um
people have mentioned so far uh already
that you know this can be easy in some
very simple cases for instance all the
groups are disjoint uh one way to
achieve this goal is just to fit
different classifier to every group I
think I have written the paper about
this at some point
um and the challenging case is
definitely when um you know they're it's
grouped overlapped because there might
be disagreements about what to do on the
point that fall into multiple multiple
subgroups
um
okay but maybe for this audience is
nothing
this is I'll just say that yeah this
kind of makes probably not too hard to
imagine that if the group really were
disjoint
fitting one class of power to each each
subgroup uh would satisfy this guarantee
surprising
um and you get the sample complexity
that you would have wanted and even in
the case where you only had to worry
about one one subgroup so here this
seems like this is extra factor of gamma
here relative to the intersection plus
the BC dimension of the group group
family G
um but this is just saying that because
you know if you have a small group that
only has mass gamma within the broader
population this is just saying that well
you need to at least just get samples
from that population and then I think
we'll be fine there's this plus DG here
okay maybe you wanted this to hold for
all the groups simultaneously or
something
but anyway not not so important
um slight also quite easy is when the
groups are not destroying but but maybe
satisfy some structural properties like
their laminar they arrange nicely into a
hierarchy something
so the more General cases when each
group can be intersecting in arbitrary
ways and this is where um this is a
fairly nice paper by um they looked at
the waves using
um outcome indistinguishability to
provide guarantees and results agnostic
learning setup
and so what they looked at uh they
developed you know kind of a
a way of uh using algorithms that
guarantee oi
um to produce a classifier that has this
multi-group guarantee and I have the
particular sample complexity that is
polynomial in kind of all the the right
quantities so it's polynomial one by
Epsilon one by gamma gamma is the mass
of the smallest group that you're
worried about and then it's only poly
logarithmic in the the cardinalities
have
um
the reference class and the family of
groups
um
so you know where we wanted to and
what's really nice about this this work
is that work Beyond just these kind of
lost minimization objectives
objects just like calibration as well
[Music]
um
okay but you know one one kind of
downside is that the way that you have
the combine uh the way you get your
final predictors that is you know kind
of this kind of functional combination
of a bunch of reference classifiers and
and indicators from this family family
of groups and you're wondering you know
one if there's something that you can do
that's much simpler and two can you get
a sample complexity guarantee that looks
much more like what you would have if
had if you had only one to worry about
so so here are our results along these
lines
oh okay sorry sorry
um
so here here are our uh we were able to
come up with um so our first result was
a kind of a simpler algorithm that we
call pre-pen and it had like a slightly
worse sample complexity in one respect
the the dependence on gamma it gets
stuff squared but then we improve the
dependence on Epsilon
um but it's still not quite optimal and
then maybe the optimal thing that you
would hope for something that we were
able to achieve uh via online learning
and this really at least when the number
of groups is finite maybe arbitrary uh
uh a sample complexity that you would
have hoped for had you only worried
about like a single group
complexity
um just from using the empirical risk
minimization
yeah so the D is the H is the BC
dimension of the reference class GG is
the BC dimension of the Stanley groups
and
you just got the interactions even
doesn't matter at all but that's a good
point I mean maybe I can say something
about that at the end yes
pretty online learning via online
learning that's it it's it you just
basically get randomized one advice
final classifier or yes some randomized
uh
ensemble
any other questions
and that will you speak to sort of uh
complexity of learning or the models
I'll think about that in the context of
the this
person I'm not going to really have time
to get into the details about the online
learning but it's just people here yes
you're doing online learning and that's
why you can't get the COPD
this morning
okay let me tell you about the the first
hour program
really extremely simple
um the pre-pen algorithm so what it's
going to Output finally is a decision
list kind of a relatively short decision
list where the uh the decision nodes
check for membership in various groups
from your family of Group G and the
predictors uh kind of the prediction
nodes are just the prediction that
you're obtained by various reference
classifiers
so decision unless it's just you know
like a bunch of nested uh if if else uh
then thing so if you're in group one
then predict using H1 of x if you're in
group two else if you're in group two
then predict using H2 effect and so on
okay
okay so one nice thing about this is you
can explain this to anyone that this is
uh basically all that's happening is
that you're ordering the various you
know some maybe some subset of the
various groups in your family of groups
and then using a particular classifier
specific to to that group
doesn't make sense for uh the like like
a this decision a predicate to appear
more than once like for for a particular
group it should only appear in which
ones
um okay and then it you know it has a
particular sample size requirement that
we show here uh again it's you know not
quite uh optimal not quite what we would
hoped for uh but some improvement at
least in terms of Epsilon over the prior
work
and I should say that this without this
algorithm is exactly independently
discovered by IRA and Michael Curran and
Aaron Roth and the Very related context
and I should say that the way that
you're going actually going to implement
this thing they've found a nice
reduction to a supervised learning uh
problem that you can implement this
algorithm uh by by using kind of some
kind of like supervised learning Oracle
so it's efficient in this kind of Oracle
particular kind of Oracle sense
okay so here's the whole algorithm it's
literally just this it looks a lot like
the algorithms that we've been seeing
with for multi-group uh calibration and
so on
um so you start with any uh reference
classifier and then you have a decision
list that always uses this classifier
and then what you do is you look at uh
you try to see if there's you know a
particular group or a reference
classifier such that for that particular
group
um
you know that that group has some
reference classifier that has a smaller
error at least based on your training
data molar conditional error than what
you are you are currently achieving by
some noticeable amount okay and if so
then just kind of CR add a new decision
node to the front of this decision list
okay prepend this kind of clause to the
front of your decision list and then and
and then keep going
so okay I already mentioned this it's
basically just determining a particular
ordering over some subset of the group
so it's very easy to understand why you
know what this predictor is doing at
least relative to the reference
predictors
um the algorithm you know in fact can
kind of loop multiple times many times
in fact use the same group in many
iterations so it's not that this always
just makes one pass through all the the
groups that um does something
potentially complicated but the analysis
is actually quite uh straightforward
um
so you know in a particular iteration we
may update the current the decision list
by pre-pending a new decision node to
the front of it and we get some new
decision lists okay
and we're going to pre-pen you know this
this new Clause to the front
if we do that that must mean that
um you know the error rate of our new
decision list but we can first decompose
it just using conditional expectations
um in this particular way if we if x
does fall into the group GT they're
going to predict using this new
reference predictor HT and that will be
will incur that error rate and if it
doesn't if it doesn't fall into GT then
we predict with the old decision list
and all that happens is that you know
because we made this update we are
guaranteed that this thing can be upper
bounded by the the error rate of the old
decision list conditional on this new
group that we found
and we know that this uh this means that
we made some some noticeable progress
relative to the old decision list
so this tells us that you cannot you
know build too long of a decision list
it tells you to bound on how many
iterations this algorithm makes
um and that that's kind of the whole
thing okay there's some you know it
looks like an Epsilon over two because
you have to worry about sample averages
being close to True averages
and this is where you think
it's not extra faster yeah yeah there's
some extra
you you balance something and something
gets is no longer one by Epsilon squared
um
okay so it would be really nice I think
to this is our first open problem that
it would be really nice to be able to do
this with the better sample complexity
with something as simple as a decision
list and you know we actually
can it tried to do this and we didn't
come up with anything one thing we did
observe is that you can't combine just
these simple first order statistics in
some some way to produce a decision list
by first order statistics I just mean
you know how large are the groups and
what's the best error rate you can
achieve using reference predictors
within that group just looking at these
statistics is not enough to tell you you
know what you should do when in the
intersection region between two groups
it's just based on these statistics
somehow you have to at least reason in
some way either implicitly or explicitly
about what happens like in the
intersection of various groups
so so this is our first problem can you
can I improve the sample complexity of
uh with something as simple as a
decision list
um
okay so the uh
since it's so simple just like make a
point that you can actually Implement
that uh this is the same data set from I
think people showed before from the
folks table package that uh Francis and
Morris and others have put together so
very easy to code up um
and you know this is the various ways of
dividing up the population to some
overlapping groups based on by Race by
sex by age so you've been definitely are
not disjoint
um
you know we compared uh what happens we
just do a logistic regression using over
on the whole population and then apply
it to the various subpopulations
um we looked at what happens if you just
use a specific uh logistic regression
model specific to each group which is
maybe what we want to compare to
and we also compared to to training a
single random force over the entire
population which was supposed to be a
pretty good Baseline and in all these
cases um you know the classifier we get
using the prepend algorithm is um seem
to be pretty competitive
um here's one exception
um I think this this particular group
doesn't have so many data points so
not so much we can do there
um what's a little bit disappointing
that I didn't show in this slide is that
the the decision list is like extremely
simple it just has actually two decision
nodes you should just uh look at whether
in your particular uh I think the group
is one of the age groups
do something for people with a
particular age above some threshold and
then do something else for everyone else
and the hypothesis class H is logistic
regression
and they all get the same size data set
yeah
it's all the same everyone's using the
same data
that's it to like fully
um right so like if you're if you run
your pre-pened uh model with a broader
hypothesis class that included uh you
know like for example in that one group
where it's it's not beating uh your brm
right
right but like as soon as you expanded
your hypothesis
to include random forests that would
just fully Beat It we would hope at
least uh
if you account for the you know number
of data within this group
um
you would beat it within within some
error margin
thank you
we didn't throw in a random course
that's one of the government predictors
okay so uh
then after the the prepann algorithm
which thinks like a practical algorithm
um so the less practical algorithm is
one that's based on online learning
um but it does get the right sample
complexity at least if you you know
first if you're working with finite a
number of groups and if you're willing
to just say that this is the best you
can do for any finite family of groups
um
and you know as you might expect this is
called because it's done by online
learning we're going to simulate an
online learning process uh
uh this is exactly the setup that uh
however yeah woman lacource looked at uh
um and then you do an online to batch
conversion at the end the online to
batch is a little bit subtle uh but
turns out it's fine as long as he did
the Jensen's inequality correctly
um
but the final predictors is kind of this
stochastic Ensemble of you know n base
classifier for n is the number of
training data that you have so it's not
particularly uh I don't think it's so
practical uh and it would be nice to do
something better
um
so I guess one I wanted to say one thing
about how we you know why we kind of are
thinking about this problem in this
particular way
um so a lot of I think the prior work in
uh
kind of largely in this a space when you
look at just sample complexity as you
know what sample size you need to
achieve a particular excess error you
know on all the sub subgroups um you
come up with these these kinds of
You Know sample complexity bounds like
this
um
and you know maybe you see like a two or
three uh maybe you're they all kind of
seem the same if epsilon's a constant
um but what the way we kind of came at
this with that we wanted to understand
like what should you expect hedgie only
had to worry about a particular subgroup
okay you only had to do machine learning
for that subgroup and so when you do
that you would fix the sample size that
you have and then ask you know how large
is the excess air uh of your classifier
for that subgroup okay and so you know
if you again if you didn't worry about
groups just rewriting what I did on this
agnostic learning slide you would say
that you know just on the broad
population the excess area you would be
able to achieve is like order uh BC
dimension of the reference class over n
turns out this is exactly matching you
know how you you know what kind of how
the the errors and the uniform
convergence bounds uh for reference for
predictors in H
um it turns out uniform conversion does
hold even for subgroups
in roughly the way you would think that
you know you look at error rates on the
subgroups of classifiers from the
reference class
um will be similar to the reference the
actual error rates uh
um conditional error rates and they
would deviate by no more than this
amount and this amount is the sum of the
two VC Dimensions divided by the number
of samples you see in training the
examples that you saw in that particular
group okay
um so this is you know this is just
saying something about you know how well
do sample averages uh uh converge to the
true averages doesn't say anything
immediately about how well you can do in
terms of learning
um and this kind of near optimal
algorithm based on online learning okay
at least when this was finite or sorry
when the number of groups was finite
kind of it gets the same thing as the
uniform convergence in this multi-group
learning problem
and so this is kind of the guarantee
that we want we don't want to think
about you know how much data do you need
for a group we wanted to think about
what error rate are we able to achieve
for a group when you know uh
um based on a fixed sample size and this
is telling you that you know for some
group where you don't have so much data
you cannot really expect
um you know the same kind of quality of
access to error rates as
um groups that have work for which you
have much more training data
okay so that's all I wanted to say
um so I really like this framework uh
this multi-group agnostic learning setup
it really kind of addresses a lot of
these issues I think from you know that
have come up in the context of machine
learning or trustworthy AI machine
learning
um it's also nice because a lot of the
same tools that we've been able to to
use from statistical learning really do
come into play here just that we maybe
need to remix some of these arithmic
ideas and there's some open problems I
think that it would be great to uh to
work out to figure out simpler
algorithms that are optimal and also
even get fully polynomial time
algorithms without this kind of Oracle
caveat
thank you very much
approach so
um I'm wondering so there's like
more complicated algorithm lots of
randomization but it's better rates uh
like if we like turn back to decision
lists that we learn uh deterministically
um how is yeah what if you were to like
can you say anything about it's about
this more complicated Ensemble
um as if it was a decision list but it's
not randomization can you somehow just
like represent it as like a decision
list yeah yeah that's so clear to us how
that would work out but that would be
one one way to I guess simplify things
some special cases like like in the case
where the the groups are hierarchically
stratified
um you do get something very simple
again with the optimal rates
great in the interest of time let's uh